on appelle ça les organismes
génétiquement modifiés ou plus
simplement les produits transgéniques
comme le maïs ou le soja
depuis que leur culture ont été
autorisés pour les états unis et même en
france pour le maïs les consommateurs de
produits bio ne savent plus à quel saint
se vouer
il essaie donc par tous les moyens de
s'assurer que les produits qu'ils
achètent sont bien 100% naturel
dominique barrau et marque une est ici
dans ce supermarché bio de la région
parisienne les pillant surveille ce
qu'ils vont mettre dans leur assiette et
le transgénique
ils sont contre manipulation ça
m'inquiète parce que ça inquiète les
plus qualifiés quoi je pense que la
maison bio quels sont les faits est ce
que je pense qu'ils sont contents des
yaourts que ce genre saucisse de soja
pâtes et de soja le soja comme le maïs
est un des éléments de base de
l'alimentation biologique pas de chance
ces deux produits sont les plus
susceptibles aujourd'hui d'être
génétiquement modifiés que faire le
chocolat qui traditionnellement utilise
de la lécithine de soja soit on a de la
lécithine de soja qui lie en duo comme
c'est indiqué soit on a des chocolats
qu'ils ont carrément arrêter
l'utilisation pour le soja
seul le produit importé en particulier
des états unis peut être transgéniques
en revanche ou maïs français est
désormais suspect depuis l'autorisation
de culture en france
deux variétés transformer le maïs
transgénique diffuse
par pollinisation sur les autres maïs
donc on va plus avoir aucune
certification sur le maïs
pourquoi comment on peut s'en sortir
sinon quand en arrêtant complètement
l'utilisation de prob où l'entreprise
tribal à 70% des yaourts bio vendus en
france n'a pas attendu le débat actuel
pour craquer les organismes
génétiquement modifiés qu'on appelle ogm
pas de lécithine de soja dans le yaourt
et dans le riz au lait l'amidon de maïs
est remplacé par la nuit dont de blé
c'est à ce prix qu'elles conservent le
label ab le label bio
l'administration a été prise de court
par la rapidité c'est à gérer et c'est
les professionnels avec plus encore
chacun des ingrédients mes yaourts sont
analysés en laboratoire en présence lui
si le combat contre le transgénique et
total produire bio ça va jusqu'à
vérifier ce que mangent les vaches